How do we get?
you
and V transpose
so for that we need to talk about the
first of all the definition of an orthogonal Matrix the
distinction of orthogonal and also normal and then
we will switch and talk about the
The gram Schmidt algorithm one of the algorithms with
which you can.
Or talk in the lights.
This is the
tutorial from week one which I have updated
an orthogonal Matrix
sometimes synonymously called
orthonormal
is a matrix that is
whose vectors?
In the column space imagine you
have a matrix.
If you take the columns as vectors.
And you take the product? Excuse me?
the Dutch product
Also known as the inner product.
So we take the dot product of two columns in that
Matrix.
And their value and the value of this product becomes zero.
Then we say that The Columns of this Matrix are
pairwise orthogonal.
What does it mean for the dot product of two vectors
to be 0 does anybody know like if you were to plot
these two vectors?
And their product is zero. What would those two
vectors look like?
Precisely they would be perpendicular.
Just like we saw in that cosine similarity example you would
get this.
remember when we when we took the cosine similarity
of
all the time dog and building the angle was quite big.
but anyway for two vectors to orthogle means
that they have
well, they're perpendicular.
if this was cosine similar, this would be they have
you know little to nothing to do with each other.
That's
that's an orthogonal matrix. It's column vectors.
We all be orthogonal to each other perpendicular.
now
In some literature if you see here in some literature an
orthogonal Matrix is a matrix to which only
the first condition applies.
So notogama Matrix is all the Matrix whose color
vectors are perpendicular.
and orthonormal Matrix
Is a matrix to which both conditions wanted to apply
what is conditioned to?
condition two says that the magnitude
of each column Vector is zero.
How do we calculate the magnitude we've seen this before
in one of the previous sessions?
This is the magnitude.
And you know also it's known as a norm.
easier synonyms
Typically you want to use double the two vertical bars.
Sometimes you will see single bars, but
this is not good practice because single bars are
also used for the absolute value.
Anyway, the week calculate the magnitude of
a vector is to take
its components. Let's say this is a vector
v over R4 so four dimensional vector.
You take all four of its components Square them.
And it add the add up
to some and then take the squares of that sum.
If that becomes zero.
Or if it becomes one that then you have a unit vector.
essentially unit vectors one who's
radius is one.
So
Here if I return to.
this other file
it's called orthonormal.
Because it's magnitude is zero.
and
there's a word called normalize.
normalize is a
normalization is where
the largest component in a vector is
one and the smallest component is in the vectors 0 this
is after normalization.
I'll show you how that's done in a moment.